[Music]
we really need to get to the bottom of
what happened at the FBI
during the Comey years James Comey sent
Andrew McCabe stood tall was this this
model leader and now he wants immunity
because he knows he's in jeopardy with
his conduct over this investigation
forgiving mr. McCabe cover through
immunity would be a mistake I would not
give him immunity I would make him go if
he's gonna plead the fifth amendment
then he should plead the fifth amendment
it's very very unusual I have to tell
you unheard of for the number two person
the FBI's saying you want me to testify
give me immunity all right let's talk
about it with our panel jonah goldberg
senior editor at national review Susan
page Washington bureau chief at USA
Today and Byron York chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
welcome to all of you today okay so this
discussion about McCabe immunity Jonah
it comes ahead of we are waiting now for
the inspector general's report are they
connected I'm sure they are connected
how in one way it remains to be seen
I personally I'm very much in favor of
getting all the information out here
whatever it is about Comey about all of
it I'm not sure it tracks to say we have
to get to the bottom of this as corn and
was saying and no way should we give
this guy immunity if that's the way you
get the information out of him that made
the argument may go the other way
seems to me there is an interest in the
optics which are very bad for me behave
very bad for Comey to have the number
two got FBI pleading the fifth but if we
actually want to get the information I'm
agnostic if he deserves to go to jail I
want to go jail if he doesn't deserve it
at all but I really think the American
people need to get the information
yeah well the US Attorney now looking
into what was found by a separate
Inspector General report about that
particular issue whether there will be
criminal liability in the meantime
Senator Chuck Grassley of course chairs
the Senate Judiciary Committee says
before even beginning to consider
whether to initiate the process of
immunity the community the committee
would need to know more a lot more about
the anticipated scope nature and extent
of your testimony so Susan it sounds
like they're leaving the door open to
the possibility well of course it says
it's a constitutional right to either
take the fifth or to demand immunity if
they expect him to testify but
I agree optics is word of the day that
the number-two guy at the FBI you do not
expect him to find himself in the
situation but he must be so surprised to
find himself in this situation too after
a career in the FBI like it's two days
away from retiring and he gets caught
into this continuing controversy over
the Clinton emails and over his the
allegation that he leaked information to
The Wall Street Journal and then mislead
investigators about it it has got to be
a shocking thing for him and his family
to be looking at well and obviously what
the Inspector General found in that
initial report was that there was some
something less than fully honest in a
number of these and he had called me
were at odds about who was right what
information they actually shared commis
praised him publicly but now should
Comey be worried about what McCabe may
say that could influence or hurt him and
there's more that call me should be
actually worried about the the
connection between the immunity request
and the IG report is because the Senate
Judiciary Committee has scheduled a
hearing to discuss the IG report once
it's made public they had scheduled one
for a June 5th that didn't happen they
scheduled the next one for next Monday
June 11th and it looks like that might
not happen but it's going to happen
fairly soon they wanted me came to
testify and now he's asked for immunity
and there's more than just the Comey vs.
McCabe I mean III leaked but you told me
I could no I didn't there's more than
that there's talk of it there's there's
information about when McCabe took a
long time recused himself after his wife
got a lot of political contributions
that were kind of linked to the Clintons
there's there and McCabe was involved in
every other decision in this Clinton
thing so it's not just call me versus
McCabe well and another name in the
obviously Susan is Peter struck I mean
how much do you think he is sort of
wringing his hands and waiting for that
report to come as well you know the
thing is he was an FBI agent working on
this case and because of these very
intemperate texts he sent to his
girlfriend denouncing President Trump he
has seen as I think tainting the efforts
he was doing when he was working for the
FBI that that may or may not be fair but
it is he is now an inflammatory name
when you see in things like
one of the one controversy the day is
the the fact that the GSA turned over a
lot of information from the transition
team to Muller without a subpoena
without going back to the Trump
transition team to get permission struck
was part of that so that so every it's
it's as though we are in such a world of
investigation that there is no element
that does not get caught up in this
spaghetti all right
also the Congress has been very busy
with investigations but now they're
going to be busy and at least the Senate
side in August thanks to Senate Leader
Mitch McConnell saying they're going to
be in session here's the top Republican
and Democrat from the Senate talking
about what they might be doing why don't
we get something done on the issue that
numerous polls say is the number one
priority of Americans health care we
Democrats our entire caucus believes
this previously unscheduled session time
can be put to good use
we need to confirm more of the
president's aim and judicial nominees we
need to take up regular appropriation
bills we need to tackle legislative
priorities like the water infrastructure
bill the farm bill the defense bill and
many others all right Jonah so both
sides have laid out a pretty ambitious
schedule does any of that get done what
does get done yeah I mean there are
conspiracy theories or it's too strong a
word but there are theories that what
McConnell is doing is trying to pull
back Democrats from the campaign trail
in August and make them be stuck here
because the Democrats have a harder time
in the Senate matchup and then there are
other people who say no this is what
this is really all about is putting a
gun to the Democrats heads so we so he
can cram more judges through I don't see
why we have to pick one of those but I
don't think that there's going to be the
some this is this is not going to be you
know that like the first hundred days of
the New Deal coming out of DC in August
all right meantime we saw the first lady
today the president had tweeted earlier
this the fake news media has been so
unfair and vicious to my wife and our
great first lady Melania during her
recovery from surgery they reported
everything from near death to facelift
to left the White House and be for New
York or Virginia to abuse all fake she
is doing really well Susan there's been
a ton of speculation but today we saw
her she did look well she looked to the
front in just a word if my husband's
watching if you're going
deny something you get denied I had a
facelift everybody okay did something
else not the approach I would like to
like to see you take you know I am I am
sort of in the leave Melania Trump alone
camp she didn't run for office she
doesn't have an office in the West Wing
she's not weighing in on policy and I
think if she wants to you know she this
got started because she was kind of out
of sight for for three weeks but if she
wants to stay out of sight for three
weeks it seems to me that's her business
and we should leave her alone well she's
back and she looks healthy and we are
all happy about that